as the number of people fleeing the war
in ukraine approaches 2 million some
rush to get to its front lines
bravery or bravado more men like this
one are coming to ukraine's aid every
day inspired perhaps by a social media
campaign
i'm in parliament right now
or a call to arms for volunteers by
ukrainian leaders under siege in their
own
capital
from our home near kiev lesia vasilenko
says there is something to do for
everyone coming to ukraine's defense we
are fighting the second biggest army in
the world and the nuclear power at that
of course our military resources are not
enough so we need more people here on
the ground we need more weapons here on
the ground we need more sophisticated
weapons here on the ground to be able to
stand and keep standing as an
independent free country this is the
struggle and the fight that we invite
the world to join in
volunteers who contact ukrainian
embassies are directed to the website
for the international legion of the
defense of ukraine
this is one of the locations recruits
can find themselves signing up and
boarding buses to cross the border we
met a ukrainian coordinator who declined
to speak on camera or give his full name
or even his rank
but he said he was there to help
volunteers find their way to the fight
this roadside motel near the border has
become a kind of unofficial recruitment
point for volunteers wanting to fight in
ukraine we've been here a few hours and
we've met people from europe the united
states great britain many more have
already crossed over many more are
expected to
julian is 22 and says he served in the
dutch military and was deployed to
afghanistan
well i'm not looking for violence per se
it's more that i'm
looking for to give the people their
hope that they see they're not alone in
this fight he's still undecided
unwilling to sign a contract to serve
until the end of the war whenever that
might be
the open-ended contract has also put off
volunteers at the medica border crossing
if they say that or you you can
stay and fight by
in three months you can go home to see
your families and come back if you want
or six months or even one year but we
know in one year we're going we're going
home but in this contract there's no
takes there's no when
we could go home you know so yeah
that was the
point for me to change mind
others remain undeterred
jay is from portugal lives in london and
says his motivation comes from his young
daughters
that he is fighting to defend their
future their freedoms the lack of action
by the west
i just personally don't think sanctions
are enough
um i understand the fear of world war
three but as you can see this is the
beginning of world war three personally
i don't think i'm being brave i'm just
doing what i'd like people to do if
the uk was under attack and boris
johnson was begging for help highly
experienced soldiers are sent to the
front line less experienced recruits are
kept back to help territorial defense
units and treat the wounded
jay says he trusts ukraine will let him
go home to see his family and is
unafraid as he commits himself to a war
that could go on for years
zain basravi al-jazeera at the ukraine
border in eastern poland